La volta al món a peu, dia 310. Ui, que em maten.
Avui sí, avui sí. Avui sí, és ben d'hora, ben d'hora, ja tocava.
Són les 12 i 10.
Anem a intentar aconseguir diners.
Us en recordeu que us vaig dir que em van ajudar per entrar a Pakistan?
Em van dir els mètodes per aconseguir anar al bus i que anés tot bé i ser el primer?
Doncs aquest mateix noi, un suís, m'ha dit on hi ha el caixer de Hunza
en el qual podré treure diners en Revolut. Treure'm el pit.
No hi ha voreres ni res, tu. Això és un absolut caos dintre la ciutat, eh?
Fora s'estava tan tranquil.
Bueno, he aconseguit treure diners, eh?
Ha costat, la taceta no acabava d'entrar, me l'ha reforçat dues vegades, però al final ho he aconseguit.
Crec que m'han cobrat 10 euros de comissió per treure 200 i pico euros.
Tampoc és tants diners que hagi tret, però bueno, mira, és el que hi ha.
Bueno, avui què?
Què?
Jo us vaig dir que demà, en principi, volia fer el trek del camp base del Raja, no sé què, que hi ha aquí,
però que potser plovia.
No ho sé.
Bueno, doncs, la previsió s'ha mantingut aquesta nit.
He mirat aquest matí i encara sembla que plourà, però bueno, no em quedaré aquí.
Si tal, continuo, que avui fa bon temps i demà ja veurem.
Bona nit.
Torna a la Pols.
Fins ara el Karakorum ho estava sent bastant lliure de pols, les carreteres ben asfaltades,
però aquí al Karakorum, aquesta part, estan, no sé si aixamplant-la, construint alguna cosa,
no sé si hi ha hagut una esgavissada o què, però, mare meva, jo no tinc la mascareta, eh?
No tinc la mascareta de Tajikistan.
El que és brutal són els camions, eh?
De Pakistan.
Us he estat ensenyant unes imatges.
Unes imatges.
Però són simplement genials. Porten un vestit, no? És com si portessin un vestit.
Si algú em pot explicar d'on ve aquesta tradició i quin sentit té, em semblen guapíssims.
400 rupís al litre de dièsel. Sembla poc, no? És 1,30 euros al litre. Però és molt, eh?
Es veu, m'ha dit el de la gasolinera, que ha pujat molt el preu respecte a l'any passat per culpa de tot el tema de la guerra.
No només aquí, però clar, aquí els sous són molt diferents, eh? I 1,30 euros és una passada.
Normalment no escolto la ràdio en directe, sempre l'escolto a posteriori en podcast o música, però ara l'estava escoltant
i he vist que s'han convocat eleccions el 28 de novembre o alguna cosa així, no? Eleccions generals.
Bé, no parlaré de política, mai parlo de política al meu canal de YouTube i seguirà sent així.
No perquè no em vulgui mullar ni res.
Sinó perquè, ostres, jo intento fer els vídeos que a mi m'agradaria veure.
I jo soc una persona que consumeixo premsa, consumeixo ràdio, llavors ja estic enterat de la política i de lo que sigui, de tot el que passa.
Hi ha inundacions ara a Catalunya, m'estan passant unes imatges del Vallès Oriental molt boges.
També estic veient imatges per allà, espero que tothom estigui bé, però les imatges són heavys.
Però bueno, dic això, que estic bastant enterat ja del tema, de tots els temes que passen.
I clar, quan jo, suposant que jo soc vosaltres, si arribo a casa per la nit, miro el vídeo de YouTube del meu youtuber preferit
i resulta que es posa a parlar de política, doncs és un pal.
Seria un pal, a mi no m'agradaria veure-ho això, per tant no parlo de política.
Però simplement dir sobre aquest tema que, ostres, no podré votar, evidentment.
Hello, I'm walking to Gilgit, thank you.
Walking.
No vaig a Gilgit avui, però bueno, en algun moment arribaré a Gilgit, val.
No, bueno, és que un home m'ha preguntat on anava amb la moto.
Perdó que estic bastant dispers, però hi ha bastantes persones que s'ofereixen a portar-me la moto,
però si encara que necessitéis autostop per algun motiu, pujar-me una moto a mi em faria respecte.
Sense casc, per la carretera del Caracorum.
Bueno, que no podré votar.
I no podré votar ni que em registri una ambaixada ni res.
Tu només pots votar des de l'estranger si estàs residint a un país estranger.
Si estàs de turisme, no pots.
I, bueno, votar per correu.
Podria demanar el vot i que algun membre de la meva família posés la butlleta, però seria frau.
Llavors no.
No ho faré, saps? Les primeres eleccions que puc votar a la meva vida que no puc votar.
Res.
Després vindran altres, eh? Vindran les municipals, les autonòmiques... Tampoc podré votar.
Què hi farem?
La meva volta al món a peu és d'oest a est.
D'esquerra a dreta. Bueno, nosaltres no sé com ho veurem, però d'esquerra a dreta.
I també, com a mínim en aquest tram, de nord a sud, més o menys.
Perquè des de Barcelona he de caminar fins a Singapur, que està més a baix, no?
Ara estic anant... No estic avançant cap a l'est, estic anant molt d'això.
De nord a sud.
Què pites?
Estic anant molt de nord a sud.
Llavors, no sé si ho sabeu, però a l'hemisferi nord el sol sempre està al sud.
Per tant, ara el tinc de cara.
A vegades el tinc més a l'esquerra, a vegades el tinc més a la dreta, però el tinc sempre de cara.
Llavors, la placa solar ara és completament inútil.
Perquè, clar, si la placa solar me la poso a l'esquena, al sol mai li donarà bé.
Sempre li donarà molt de refilón, no? De resquí.
De lletjada.
Però bueno, com que aquí a Pakistan hi ha força llocs per parar, doncs no pensava que fos així, al nord de Pakistan.
Bueno, a Nepal jo crec que sí que serà més útil, perquè sí que aniré més d'oest a est.
Allà és on d'això, on crec que pot funcionar bastant.
Però bueno, en referència a això, clar, quan jo faig fotos o vídeos mirant cap a baix perquè veig el paisatge cap endavant, que és maco,
es veu com molt a contrallum, en canvi, quan el faig cap amunt,
que no és tan intuïtiu per mi perquè m'he de girar per veure el paisatge que tinc a l'esquena,
doncs es veu més guapo.
Ho he de tenir més en compte perquè, clar, si no es veu com molt blanquinós i...
Sí.
A mesura que m'hi apropo, cada cop impressiona més.
Rakaposhi, 7.788 metres sobre el nivell del mar,
27a muntanya més alta del món,
i atenció amb la...
Ua, la glacera aquesta no l'havia dit fins ara, eh?
Doncs, des de la base, és a dir, des del fons del riu,
que és on anem ara, fins a la punta,
hi ha 6.000 metres, 6 quilòmetres, no ho sembla, eh?
Sembla que diguis, mira,
amb un puix d'un o dos dies, faig així, faig així, ja la tens.
Però no, no, que va.
6.000 metres des de la base fins a la punta, eh?
Les 5.45, mira.
He de baixar fins allà baix, aquí està la carretera,
hauré de fer un petit agonses, creuar el pont,
i després tornar a pujar fins a alguna d'aquestes queuseus o el que sigui on em quedaré.
Ah, doncs no, el pont no surt marcat al mapa,
el veig des d'aquí, no sé si és perquè és massa nou,
tampoc veig clar el camí d'arribada, no veig on està, no l'he vist en cap moment,
que no sigui que això és una espècie de central
i el pont és només per a ell, saps?
Bé, podria arriscar-me, intentar trobar el camí, baixar, creuar-lo,
però no, veig allà, aniré pel que marca el mapa, que és aquell d'allà.
Bé, doncs he de donar bastanta més volta.
Però, per res, doncs ja està.
He vist una gent ara acampada a la vora del riu.
Molta gent, no sé què feien, eh?
No crec que visquin allà, no.
No ho sé.
Però estàvem buscant or, com els d'Afganistan.
Bé, aquí comença la desviació que m'arribarà fins a Minapin,
que és el poble des d'on comença l'excursió al camp base del Rakaposhi.
Típic nom que diré 40 vegades diferent i 40 vegades malament.
I, per tant, no sé què farà.
Una de les regles de la World Runners Association,
l'associació que controla que estigui fent la volta al món a peu,
és que tu no pots repetir una ruta per la que hi hagis anat, no?
Per exemple, si jo ara vaig fins al camp base del Rakaposhi
i després torno, que és el mateix camí,
és com que no estic avançant, estic fent com un loop.
Només permet que gravis els quilòmetres mentre avances.
Una regla general, tampoc cal ser superestrictes allò de si has passat per un carrer
o has fet una volta per una ciutat, no?
Però, bé, en aquest cas sí que em desvio de la carretera com abans
i ara pujo fins al camp base i demà o demà passat tornaré.
Per tant, he parat el trec allà i, com ja no estic gravant,
doncs sí, m'ha agafat un cotxe i m'ha provat uns 3 quilòmetres,
fins aquí.
En aquest poble deuen estar molt acostumats
a que vinguin els turistes a fer el trec del camp base
perquè ni em miren, ni em somriuen, ni em diuen res.
Sembla com que molesti una mica i tot.
Aquest és l'esport nacional, el críquet, esport que desconec completament.
He demanat permís als nens perquè em deixin gravar.
No sé ni una regla d'aquest esport.
Thank you!
We don't see.
Other place.
What do you recommend?
Natural.
OK.
Can you show me?
Picture?
Yeah.
A veure.
No sé si es veurà.
Ah!
This national.
Not national.
Natural.
Oh, look.
This is...
Amazing.
Another place.
Capuixi.
OK.
We will go.
We can go there.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Bye.
OK.
What's your name?
Camil Tuarguait.
You are from here?
Yeah.
From Minapit.
OK.
We will put your social media here if anyone wants to hire your services.
Thank you, sir.
Doncs ja hem sopat.
Pujastre abundant.
Abundant.
Proteïna.
Molt bé.
Bastant bo.
I després...
Bueno, jo no ho sabia quan he arribat aquí, però resulta que a part de tenir aquesta guesthouse,
amb aquesta habitació que està força bé,
12 euros,
m'ha costat,
doncs hi ha uns dels nois que viuen aquí que és Guia,
aquest noi que us he ensenyat,
que aquí teniu per posar-vos en contacte amb ell per si voleu fer un trek aquí per aquí.
Clar,
a mi no em sol agradar molt anar amb Guia,
però bueno,
ja que estava aquí i tal,
bueno,
he estat parlant amb ell,
clar,
m'oferia els seus serveis.
Hi ha un altre noi,
hi ha un altre noi aquí,
un belga,
que no ha volgut sortir del vídeo,
que,
bueno,
potser,
unes fotos i és guapíssim. I
li he dit, ostres, però creuar
la glacera? I diu, sí, sí, tranquil, però es pot,
no sé què, bueno, sense gran ponts, sí, sí, sí,
bueno, ok, ok, ja ho veurem.
El fet que, bueno,
jo no sabia molt bé què fer demà per el tema
de la pluja, i ell m'ha dit, mira,
hem mirat una mica la mete o tal, demà
per pujar al can Bas aquest
millor que no, perquè hi haurà
núvols i no es veurà res.
Per tant, demà, que jo
us havia dit que potser em quedava aquí i no m'ho havia,
demà no caminava, diu, no,
no, demà anem a un altre
lloc, mira, no us faré espòilers, el lloc on aniré demà,
però té molt bona
pinta el lloc on aniré demà, no és
tan èpic com muntanyes glaçades,
però és un lloc que té pinta de ser bastant
guapo, i demà passat,
llavors ja fem el trekking aquest de
el can Bas d'un, el can Bas
de l'altre, i tornem.
Per tant, doncs això serà
el que farem, jo crec.
Molt bé, sí,
m'alegro d'haver acabat aquí, per casualitat, tu,
amb el belga i amb el guia aquest.
Que, per cert,
ha vist, jo crec que
han vist que tinc molts seguidors a les xarxes
socials, i ara volen que els hi
faci una mica de promoció, però bé, està bé,
està bé, que si es porten bé i ho fan
bé, els hi farem promoció.
D'acord,
un parell de preguntes vostres
que m'heu fet arribar.
Pregunta número 1, em pregunteu
per què porto pantalons llargs?
Si és per tema
religió o tal.
Me'l vaig comprar a Uzbekistà,
perquè jo sabia que em podien anar bé a
Tajikistà, i
els porto ara,
a pesar que dic que fa calor,
perquè sí que és veritat que les hores centrals del dia,
doncs,
fa calor, sí,
i portaria pantaló curt, però
pel matí, i sobretot
per la tarda de nit, quan comença a baixar una mica el sol,
doncs va bé,
va bé tenir el pantaló llarg,
i encara que siguin les hores centrals
del migdia, el fet de
no haver-se de posar crema de sol a les cames,
home, doncs, també és un punt.
Encara que faci una mica més de calor,
el pantaló és bastant gasós, tal.
No, jo no tinc cap problema, eh? Si aquí la gent
per cultura no porta pantaló curt,
a mi m'ha
mala bufa. He estat per
països on ningú portava pantaló curt
a Tajikistà, i jo portava el pantaló curt.
I bé, és igual, jo soc turista,
s'accepta. També algú altre
m'ha dit que em queda molt curt.
Jo crec que sí, queda curt,
ja es veu, però crec que és l'estil d'us
bequistan. Quan el vaig a comprar, jo crec que la gent
allà el porta així, és aquest rotllo.
Bé, clar, així no, però així,
sí, és aquest rotllo.
Segona pregunta sobre el filtre d'aigua.
Si algun dia que m'hagi quedat
amb set que no hagi trobat
aigua... Algun dia
que m'ha passat ho he explicat, i
que he dit, ostres, porto una hora sense aigua,
tinc bastanta set, però bé, més o menys
sabia que
hi hauria aigua en algun riu,
o tal, i com ja sabeu, com
la majoria de vegades camino
per carreteres o en passant cotxes,
algun cop he demanat aigua
a un cotxe fet així, a Tajikistan,
vaig fer així amb una ampolla d'aigua i em van donar
una ampolla de Fanta i
un altre dia també una ampolla d'aigua.
Per tant, aquest no hi ha problema.
I el filtre d'aigua, doncs,
el vull canviar.
Sí, el vull canviar perquè
ja toca,
ha reduït una mica
la seva velocitat,
segueix funcionant bé, però
també el soft flask té
bastants forats, llavors com faig així comença a sortir aigua
pels foradets i
aquí és molt difícil aconseguir el soft flask
de la marca
aquesta que vaig servir, llavors
jo crec que si tal ja em compro tot el sense
el filtre nou i ja està.
Com ja sabeu, em farà una visita
ara quan estigui a l'Índia i em portaran
bastantes coses
insalat. Bueno, i que
m'oblido de fer el resum, tanta pregunta.
Resum avui, vint i
pocs quilòmetres,
quatre refrescos,
m'he gastat, mira, m'he gastat
només 15 euros, però falta el sopar, que va
a part i no l'he pagat. Doncs bueno,
posa-li, no ho sé, però posa-li que serà
17, 18,
alguna cosa així.
He parlat amb avui
res, dues persones aquí
i de cafès
cap un,
un cafè i cap te.
Ara sí, ja ho tenim tot.
Bona nit.